a medida que sus cauces arenosos se van
ensanchando algunas partes del río más
largo de francia son casi irreconocibles
esta es una foto del loft tomada hace 7
años
hoy se puede cruzar a pie
en el sureste las populares ghost tider
no están casi secas
[Música]
el lago cercano registra su nivel más
bajo nunca antes visto y no es el único
que se ha evaporado parcialmente durante
el verano
en algunas zonas de los alpes la nieve
prácticamente desapareció esta imagen de
satélite fue grabada hace un año un
fuerte contraste con la cantidad de
nieve presente en algunos de los picos
de 3000 metros en la actualidad desde
hace un tiempo un famoso glaciar pierde
entre 6 y 8 metros de espesor cada año
con las olas de calor que estamos
sufriendo esperamos que pierda entre 10
y 12 metros de espesor es decir 4 más
que los años anteriores y este verano es
actualmente el más seco que ha vivido
francia desde 1959